pigs
some can glow in the dark
and swim in the ocean
but you won't believe what they do
better than a preschooler
eventually pigs will rule the world
plus
wolves
they're over 20 grainier than dogs
and they can change the shape of rivers
with their teeth
but you're about to find out how they're
less lethal to humans than tap water
i don't want to say stop drinking tap
water but it could kill you
and crows
they're as smart as dolphins
and can talk like parrots
but when it comes to hunting down
terrorists
they may be as effective as seal team
six
they're not just paying attention to a
few dangerous people but they've got a
whole network of people
[Music]
this is where savage meets science
and wild becomes
wow
[Music]
this is
everything you didn't know about animals
[Music]
they can detect smells buried two
stories underground
they can make sounds almost as loud
as a jet engine
they've been known to weigh more than a
1969 volkswagen bug
and some
can even glow in the dark
they snort
they squeal
and they're on every continent but
antarctica
they're pigs
[Music]
pigs are some of the most interesting
fascinating awesome animals out there
[Music]
they're incredibly clever they're
incredibly fast they're curious they're
fun they're great animals
[Music]
but a lot of people don't see swine for
the amazing animals that they are
so we're about to put pigs through a
series of challenges
mini aptitude tests designed to flip how
we feel about our forcing pals
it's only fitting
that the battle should begin with the
biggest of all pigs foes
it's pig versus perception
[Music]
the public's pretty incorrect in most of
its perceptions about pigs
they think the pigs is dirty they think
of pigs as you know sloppy but pigs
actually in fact are quite clean animals
newborn piglets will leave their nest to
relieve themselves elsewhere when
they're only a few hours old no diapers
required
but if pigs are really so clean
then how do you explain this
[Music]
it's not because they like to be dirty
it's because that helps keep them cool
which leads to something else we have
wrong about pigs
ever uttered the phrase sweats like a
pig
well here's why that makes no sense
[Music]
humans have about two to five million
functional sweat glands under our skin
chimpanzees between two and five hundred
thousand
and the pig
zero
and what about the phrase eats like a
pig
[Music]
one might be okay
for round two of our piggy reprogramming
we're bringing in man's best friend
it's pig versus dog
more specifically the dog's nose
for years dogs have been used to sniff
out everything from drugs to bombs
and even people but theirs is not the
only nose in town
pigs can detect smells from up to seven
miles away
and may be able to pick up odors as far
as 25 feet
underground
that's deeper than a lot of nuclear
bunkers
pigs may even be muscling in on some of
dog's territory they're being trained to
detect land mines and to detect
explosives they have a really amazing
sensory apparatus
so whose nose really knows better
[Music]
one of the ways scientists measure an
animal's ability to smell is by counting
the number of genes in its dna related
to smell
for example
humans have 387 active olfactory genes
our sense of smell is just okay
but dogs have more than twice that with
811
as for pigs they have a remarkable 1113
active genes related to smell
and just how good is that
we had pigs that we trained to find a
particular odor out of an array of 10
others
and we had pigs that could terminate
between
mint peppermint and spearmint
once they learned which odor they were
trained to detect they were 100 accurate
every single time
so the winner of round two i tell you
what pigs are dogs pigs or dogs i'm
picking a pig
[Music]
for round three we're changing the way
you think about pigs by taking a look at
how they think about everything
it's a test of mental prowess
pigs versus kids
[Music]
according to some studies pigs are the
fourth smartest creatures in the animal
kingdom ranking only behind dolphins
chimps and elephants
[Music]
but how do they stack up against humans
[Music]
piglets will recognize their own name
just a few weeks after being born
it takes most human babies between five
and seven months but it gets more
advanced
one of the things that i had to do for
my phd
research was to teach pigs how to use
computer tests
watch the screen
so in fact we put pigs on a computer
task that at that point time was used to
train non-human primates racist monkeys
chimpanzees and so on
just to see if they can even get the
concept of operating a joystick that
moved a cursor on a screen
you watching the screen
and shocking off on that computer task
the pigs actually learned and performed
at a rate that was comparable to monkeys
and not just monkeys
the pigs also learned the task at a much
higher speed than three-year-olds who
played the same game
but for undeniable proof that pigs are
smarter than kids
we trained our pigs to put all their
toys back into tubs when they were done
so watching pigs walk around a room
picking up basically dog toys and nicely
carrying them back to their little tubs
is highly entertaining to watch too
[Music]
if that doesn't change the way pigs are
perceived consider this they've been
saving human lives for decades
[Music]
and for round four pigs are taking on
human diseases
[Music]
according to some research many of the
pig's organ systems are 80 to 90 similar
to our own
for years doctors have researched using
genetically modified pig hearts on
humans in need of transplants
while primates are more closely related
to us
adult pig hearts are closer in size to
our own carry a lower risk of infection
than other primate hearts
and can likely be transplanted
regardless of blood type
and it's not just a theory
researchers recently transplanted a
heart from a genetically modified pig
into a baboon
the next step will be pig to human
if successful it could save up to 1 000
lives in the u.s every year
but lately scientists have been
eliminating the pig's life-saving
abilities like never before
meet the pigs
that glow in the dark
in 2005 researchers at the national
taiwan university injected pig embryos
with bioluminescent dna from jellyfish
the results
the world's first fully glowing pigs
scientists are developing methods for
extracting green glowing stem cells from
these pigs
to use for tracing diseases inside the
human body
without the need for biopsies or other
invasive procedures
pigs haven't always been used with such
sophistication
in the not so distant past pigs were
used as instruments of war squaring off
against other armored animals
can you guess which of these other
animals the pig has had to face on the
battlefield
is it a
tigers
b
elephants
or c
lions
[Music]
winston churchill once said dogs look up
to us cats look down on us
pigs treat us like equals
to return the favor we're putting the
pig through a series of challenges
designed to change how we think about
these amazing animals
but first
before the break we asked you which of
these animals the pig has had to face
off against on the battlefield
is it a
tigers
b
elephants
or c
lions
the answer
it's the biggest of the big
the elephant
as early as 267 bc the romans deployed
war pigs against the elephants of
opposing forces
[Music]
the loud squealing of the pigs would
terrify the elephants and send them
trampling back over their own troops
pigs won
elephant zero
[Music]
[Applause]
but how loud do you have to be to scare
off a horde of battle-hardened
pachyderms
it's pig versus a jet engine
at an ear splitting 130 decibels
a pig squeal is four times louder than a
chainsaw
pigs are definitely among the loudest
animals on the planet it's pretty
amazing and literally ear ending
pigs can squeal to the point where yeah
you really can lose your hearing
if you're in a barn full of pigs and
they're all squealing at the same time
what you may often hear especially
around feeding time is a lot of
vocalization
and it's really important that people
wear hearing protection
but how does the pig squeal
stack up against the sound of a jet
engine
put them both on a runway and the engine
will only drown out the pig by 10
decibels
to put that in perspective that 10
decibel difference is only as loud
as a pin dropping
so technically jet engine wins this
battle
but just wait until pigs learn to fly
the largest pig ever recorded was named
big bill
he was five feet tall
nine feet long
and weighed a scale tipping
2552 pounds
that's 700 pounds heavier than a 1969
volkswagen bug
bill's size was definitely the exception
much to the relief of pig bombs
everywhere
especially since pigs are the most
prolific large mammals on earth
with the average litter size equaling
about 12 piglets
the biggest litter on record was 37
piglets
that's more than three defensive
lines in iowa pigs outnumber people
seven to one
with roughly a billion pigs on earth
it only makes sense that they should
face off against each other
so to really change how you feel about
swine
it's time to go back to the beginning
it's pig versus pig
the ultimate sibling rivalry
the fighting starts on day one pigs
establish hierarchies very very early on
in life and what's really cool and
interesting about them that many people
might not know is when they come out
piglets actually pick a teat and keep it
and defend it virtually for their entire
time that they're with their moms
and since the teats at the front of
mom's body produced the most milk the
first born pigs claim those right away
they come out with these nasty little
razor sharp needle teeth
that they can use to basically fight
each other off from you know within the
first few minutes of life it's sad to be
the back end of the litter because one
odds are you're not gonna get a whole
lot of milk and two you're probably
gonna stay small relative to uh to your
siblings little sisters never get any
respect
[Music]
if all of these challenges haven't
changed the way you think about pigs
maybe it's time to take a trip
to pig island in the bahamas
somewhere along the way someone brought
a few pigs to the island
now they call it home
these guys learn that if they swim out
they get close to buildings people throw
food at them it just shows how clever
pigs are
pigs in paradise
[Music]
they can solve puzzles better than some
five-year-old children
they hold funerals for their dead
they were part of the hunt
for osama bin laden
they may just be the smartest birds in
the world hello hello hello
and they live in our own backyards
ravens and crows are next
[Music]
they've been known to eat humans
they never forget a face
and they've been trained to go to war
they're ravens and crows
but don't be scared
crows also like to play like puppies
and they're as brainy as apes
forget the parrot hello
hi
crows and ravens might just be the
smartest birds in the world to back that
statement up
we're examining all the ways in which
crows and ravens transcend their scary
rep by being so clever
and it all starts with this crows are
smart enough to tell you off
[Music]
your ears do not deceive
i know
crows and ravens really can't speak
and while edgar allan poe turned talking
blackbirds into something scary
the reality i love you
when you raise captive gross
occasionally they will mimic people's
voice and often they only talk to one
person they're actually paying attention
and trying to communicate usually with
that specific individual
pet crows are said to give their owners
names in the form of specific sounds
they only use around that person i know
right now
but in the wild crows have their own
unique way of communicating
and their language may be richer than
anyone ever realized we know that crows
and ravens have extremely varied
vocabulary and a very rich vocabulary
with some calls that have very specific
meanings
[Applause]
crows even seem to have their own
accents and regional dialects
it was the great philosopher groucho
marx who said
i'd never forget a face but in your case
i'll be glad to make an exception
would probably appreciate that quote
because no joke
some of them are so smart
they never forget a face
in a first of its kind study university
of washington professor john marsloff
wanted to see if crows could recognize
individual human faces
or at least human face masks
[Music]
in mars lift's experiment researchers
wore a mask designated as a dangerous
face while trapping and tagging just
seven crows
they are fearful they are
stressed out they are thinking they're
gonna die
the crows were then released and to mars
love surprise over three years later the
crows still freak out when they see the
dangerous face
even if it's disguised with a hat
[Music]
even more incredible though john only
captured seven birds in the original
experiment over 70 percent of the crows
on campus now react anytime the mask is
around
that means that not only did the
original seven birds remember the face
but they taught other crows to hate it
too
i mean it's like a culture has developed
on our campus to hate this particular
guy this caveman the alarm calling has
increased in intensity over time it has
not faded
but if crows can single out one face in
a school of 40 000 students
what else could they do with their power
that's what the pentagon wanted to know
when in the mid-2000s they looked into
using crows to hunt down the most wanted
man in history
even they knew
crows are smart enough to hunt osama bin
laden
never mind seal team six crows might
just be the future of covert warfare
when the wars in afghanistan and iraq
were in full swing the u.s military
funded research into using a network of
spycrows to find soldiers missing in
action by studying pictures of their
faces
but it didn't stop there based on john
mars love's research at the university
of washington
the government actually looked into
whether they could be helpful in finding
osama bin laden
if they could train local crows to hate
bin laden's face like the campus crows
hated marslow's mask
the angry birds might be able to confirm
his location
so did crows and ravens have a part in
capturing bin laden in 2011
that's top secret and this time the
crows aren't talking
for centuries it was believed that true
intelligent thought could only exist in
mammalian brains
but in 2013 german neurosciences
discovered something strange in the
crow's brain
something that could lead to some
incredible human advancements
could what we know about the crow's
brain help us
a
talk to aliens b
create autonomous drones
or c look through walls with our phones
plus find out what makes some crows
smarter than chimps
in 2013
neuroscientists in germany wired
electrodes to the brains of crows
and monitored them while the birds
solved a series of complex memory tests
what they found could lead to a pretty
amazing human advancement
[Music]
before the break we asked you what that
advancement might be
by studying a crow's brain
could we learn to
a talk to aliens
b create autonomous drones
or c
look through walls with our phones
as far out as it sounds
the answer is a
if aliens exist
pros might help us learn to communicate
with them
the key is the bird's brain which is the
closest thing to alien intelligence that
we know of
when us mammals are trying to reason
something out we use our prefrontal
cortex
birds have no prefrontal cortex
their seed of reason is in a completely
different part of the brain
known as the needle pallium caudilateral
[Applause]
based on the german study some people
believe understanding how a brain so
different than our own works can help us
communicate with future visitors
or at least build smarter scarecrows
as long as we're comparing brains in
relation to the size of their bodies
crow and ranger grains are about the
same size as those of great apes
[Music]
and just like these intelligent primates
the blackbirds can use tools
they may be better at it than any chimp
this is the new caledonian crow
in the wild this indigenous bird uses
long sticks to reach tasty bugs
but they don't just use tools
they make them
they make hook tools they make barb
tools
you can teach a chimpanzee to do that
but they're not very good at it
[Music]
here a crow named betty tries to
retrieve a little basket of food
but all she has is a straight piece of
wire
[Music]
with just a little thinking she turns
the wire into a hook
no one taught her to do it
she figured out herself
i mean she really had to have had a plan
in her head if this is how this is going
to work
and that went through step by step and
the sequencing of a complex behavior
[Music]
that implies insight we don't associate
it with many animals
but we do it with this
crow betty is currently earning a degree
in it tech repair
if crows are so smart
then why do so many people still look at
them as symbols of fear
it may go back to the bubonic plague
when over 75 million people on three
continents lay dead or dying
there are no vultures in northern europe
so it's the crows and ravens that ate
the dead
you'd have a fur raven come right onto
your deck and eat a piece of bread
and two minutes later it could be eating
your neighbor who happened to have died
from the plague
crows have come a long way since then
today if they want to grab a meal it's a
little easier because when it comes to
getting food
crows and ravens are regular einsteins
in just one four-month breeding season
a small family of crows can eat over 40
000 bugs
that's more than the entire population
of moscow idaho
in bugs
but it's not all grubs and worms for
crows
they also like to eat what we eat
from leftover chinese food
to
this
they can fish
some crows drop
bait in the water
and wait for fish to come up and then
grab them
appetit
a taste for the finer things in life
isn't the only way crows are like us
after a hard day's work
they like to cut loose too
yes that crow is sledding
and it doesn't stop there
they'll play fetch
[Music]
frolic in the snow
and swing around on branches if there's
nothing better to do
play is a very beneficial activity
it helps establish social relationships
relieve stress
it's beneficial for animals just like
it's beneficial for us
it's one of the ways they keep the
family together and when it comes to
family crows may be as advanced as
humans
fall in love
move to the burbs
raise some kids
it's the american dream
and for many crows it's the same story
american pros
have a social system that is
more similar to western
society humans
than probably any other animal on earth
for instance
american crows mate for life crow
couples stake out a piece of territory
to raise their yawn
and when unclaimed real estate is hard
to come by
crow kids will often live with their
parents to help raise their younger
siblings
or as we humans call it
freeloading
those gangs and crows you see in your
neighborhood they're actually families
with mom and dad and kids from a number
of different years that are all hanging
together and watching out for each other
and they really come together when
there's a death in the family
because when it comes to the end
crows and ravens may actually hold
funerals for their dad
[Applause]
[Music]
when they see a dead crow on the ground
they will swarm around that
it's a social gathering on a huge level
there could be a thousand birds even
that gather around some of these
situations
and according to observers it seems to
be much more than just morbid curiosity
they've described the crows processing
by the body bringing sticks around the
body or just a gathering in the trees
that is very noisy
then the birds disperse silently
so maybe it's time we all pay our
respects
to the brainy birds in our backyard
one pack can dominate a territory the
size of delaware
they're being studied by the navy to
create robots of war
they're resistant to anthrax
can hunt for three days straight
and without them
trees will die
these are no puppies
they're wolves next
[Music]
it's late on the m23 highway in southern
russia
traffic cops stop a man with a burnt out
headlight
the officer is prepared to let the
driver go with a warning but then
he gets a warning of his own
something is stirring in the shadows
there's only seconds to run
the wolves are coming
[Music]
from little red's grandma to those three
sheltered pigs
we've learned to fear the big bad wolf
[Music]
but put away those silver bullets
because we're revealing four reasons to
choose respect over revulsion when it
comes to wolves
our first reason to respect the wolf is
simple
because they respect us
it's easy to understand why some people
might not see it this way
prior to the 20th century wolves killed
681 people in france alone
[Music]
but that was then
in north america there have been only
two fatal wolf attacks in the past 100
years
to put that in perspective in the us
alone roughly 20 people are killed every
year by cows
[Music]
[Applause]
100 people are killed annually by
scalding tap water
that means your average faucet kills 98
more people in one year than wolves have
killed in an entire century
wolves are not really a threat unless
you
put yourself in a really precarious
situation by getting too close so keep
your distance and wolves will mind their
own business
[Music]
whether it's the jumping jack russell or
a bounding black lab
all domestic dogs come from gray wolves
even now there's only a 0.2 difference
between the dna of a domestic dog and a
gray wolf
but it's a mistake to treat these
predators like puppies
because contrary to what some people
believe wolves deserve much more respect
than that
to be fair wolves may have started this
misconception themselves
wolves domesticated themselves to hang
out with people so that they could get
our garbage our refuge and our table
scraps
the more docile wolf with the smaller
teeth the floppier ears the shorter face
people would have tolerated them and so
over time their noses have shrunk their
teeth have shrunk their behavior has
changed dramatically from wild wolves
[Music]
but wolves in the wild have remained
very much the same they're not docile
they're not domesticated they're not
dogs
they're bigger over two times bigger
than the beefiest german shepherd
they're smarter
wolves brains are up to 30 percent
larger making them too clever to train
some researchers believe domestic dogs
only ever develop to the mental stage of
a 10 to 30 day old wolf puppy
[Music]
so because of their cunning and
unpredictability it's probably a good
thing that it's illegal in all 50 states
to own a pure wolf as a pet
i don't know if i'd 180 pound badass
killer living in my in my living room
then again tap water could kill me
okay maybe maybe i'll get a wolf for
christmas
[Music]
in january of 2013
the saka republic of siberia declared a
state of emergency
an unprecedented super pac of over 400
wolves invaded a small town of 1300
people
that's almost one wolf for every three
residents
in just four days the super pac killed
30 horses
some believe the wolves were driven
together because of a decline in their
usual prey
and a giant pack like this is extremely
rare
but the truth is even small packs are
something to be respected
in alaska
one small pack of just 10 wolves
controlled a territory of about 2
500 square miles for years
that's bigger than delaware
wolf packs are so good at hunting
together even the department of defense
respects their force
in 2014 darpa launched project code
which stands for collaborative
operations in denied environment
the goal is to mimic the way coordinated
wolf packs hunt with minimal
communication
to create semi-autonomous military
drones that can enter enemy airspace
then work together to evade and attack
by the time the plan is fully
implemented in 2018 the total cost will
be 54.3 million dollars
for years researchers gave the leader in
a wolf pack the title
alpha wolf
it seemed to make sense
webster's even defines alpha
is having the most power in a group of
animals or people
but recently there have been some
changing thoughts about the term alpha
wolf
[Music]
can you guess which of the following
statements about alpha wolves is true
the alpha wolf is a the most physically
fit
b the firstborn
or c
a
lie plus true or false where wolves
exist
[Music]
in 1951 135 french people were
hospitalized and six people died
after being attacked by werewolves
either that
or they were suffering from violent mass
hallucinations brought on by a rare
fungus in rye bread called ergot
that creates crazed delusions of
turning into beasts
some scholars now believe at least a few
of our modern werewolf legends came from
true tales of medieval peasants infected
by this same fungus and having visions
of turning into beasts
so maybe the only thing you really need
to fear during a full moon
is moldy bread
[Music]
before the break we asked you which of
these statements about alpha wolves is
true
is the alpha wolf
a the most physically fit
b the firstborn or c
a lie
the truth is according to more recent
research
the term alpha wolf is c
a lie
there's no such thing not how we think
about it anyway
so a lot of pacs are essentially family
groups so what most people would call
mom and dad we're calling you know the
alpha wolf and
his lady friend
[Music]
so they gave us dogs but what else are
wolves good for
even president teddy roosevelt regarded
as a hero to conservationists
famously called wolves a beast of waste
and destruction
so for our fourth and final reason to
respect the wolf we look at a world
without them to see if it would really
be a better place
[Music]
[Applause]
yellowstone
the world's first national park
nearly 35 000 square miles of pristine
nature
with 67 different species of mammals 322
different birds
and countless rare plants and trees it
is a true eden on earth
at least it is today
between 1914 and 1926
under pressure from cattle and livestock
industries
congress allowed the last of
yellowstone's 136 wolves
to be hunted
into extinction
and then the unexpected happened the
land started changing the trees began to
disappear
a little over two decades after wolves
new tree growth drops to just 10 percent
of what it was before their absence
50 years after wolves and those same
trees
are down to just one percent
trees that once grew up to 98 feet tall
now rarely reach a height beyond two
feet
that's like turning the sears tower into
a four-story building one of the major
reasons the trees aren't growing
they're being devoured by one of the
wolves favorite meals
the elk
if you're an elk in yellowstone things
are great
alco will eat anything that's
up to about seven feet tall so if you
have a sapling that is growing up and
hasn't made it to seven feet yet elk can
come along and just eat it and that tree
will not become an adult and reproduce
more trees
[Music]
without wolves to help keep them in
check
the elk population explodes to 19 000
strong
and with each elk devouring 10 to 20
pounds of plants per day
[Music]
that's 380 000 pounds of species
supporting habitat eaten every 24 hours
[Music]
to put it in human terms that would be
like losing two to four single level
houses every day
the entire town of danville iowa will be
wiped off the map in as little as three
months
[Music]
river banks start to crumble without the
roots of trees and plants to hold them
together
the beaver population that depends on
the rivers and the dwindling trees drops
from 25 colonies
to just one
even grizzlies one of yellowstone's
biggest draws seem to be disappearing
which only disrupts the food chain
further
70 years after their eradication
and this world without wolves
is dying
but then
in 1995
thanks to provisions in the endangered
species act
two wolf packs are reintroduced to
yellowstone
the impact is palpable
[Music]
in just a little over 10 years elk
populations dropped 50.3 percent to a
more sustainable 7 000 heads
[Music]
but it may be more than just how wolves
kill elk some studies suggest they also
keep them running so they can't over
graze any one area
and less elk competing for food means
more bison in the years after wolves
return bison populations in yellowstone
double from under 1 000 to over two
and because wolves eat big game animal
they actually were leaving behind
carrion that were being scavenged by
ravens bald eagles and even bears so
there was an increase in the bear
population 15 years after the return of
wolves and even the shape of rivers
start to change
deeper roots means stronger soil
and more defined riverbanks
yellowstone goes from having one beaver
colony
to over 100
while there are other factors at play
the wolf's impact on yellowstone's
biodiversity is undeniable
after the return of top predators like
wolves yellowstone begins to recover
this interconnectedness
is known to scientists as a trophic
cascade
and it goes beyond yellowstone from
glacier national park to the smoky
mountains
wolves are a vital part of a complex
ecosystem
and if that's not reason enough to
respect the wolf
what is
[Music]
you